so many of you wrote to me about
anti-vaccine Diamond of diamond and silk
Fame dying of covet and everything we
know right now does suggest she did die
of covid although there are still
remaining questions over this diamond
and silk were this Duo of trump
supporters who became sort of well-known
because Trump promoted them and would
sometimes invite them on stage they were
vehemently anti-vaccine they also
um were confused about a lot of
different issues including the price of
mangoes as many of you know but that's a
completely different story uh the belief
right now is indeed that the death was
the result of covid they were very
aggressively anti-vaccine which we will
talk about AP reports Diamond of the
pro-trump duo diamond and silk dead at
51. Lynette Hardaway uh an Ardent
supporter of President Donald Trump and
half of the duo diamond and silk has
died
Hardaway known by the moniker Diamond
carved out a unique role I'll say as a
black woman who loudly backed Trump her
promotion of coveted falsities
eventually got her dropped from Fox News
but she landed on another right wing
cable platform the pairs verify Twitter
account asked people to quote please
pray for diamond in a November tweet but
did not elaborate on the circumstances
Newsweek reports was Lynette hardaway's
cause of death covid what we know what
we don't
um on Monday evening the Duo's Twitter
page confirmed Hardaway had died but
asked for privacy and did get gave no
information on the manner of death
um the article goes on to say some
social media users claimed Hardaway died
from covid but it has not been confirmed
by the family or her group page many of
these claims are made on the basis of a
report from the website blavity which
now appears to be unavailable Daily
Beast reporter will summer highlighted
the Tweet I'm seeing claims that diamond
of diamond and silk a coveted vaccine
hater died of covid and was hospitalized
for it but the truth is her cause of
death isn't clear yet and the November
claims that she had coveted came from a
blavaty article that appears to have
been deleted
um Maga supporter Diamond of diamond and
silk has been hospitalized due to covid
was reported in November but that is
based on that underlying report which
now is unclear as to its truth
what we do know is that Donald Trump put
out a statement about the death of
diamonds saying quote really bad news
for republicans and frankly all
Americans are beautiful Diamond of
diamond and silk has just passed away at
her home in the state she loved so much
North Carolina
silk was wither all the way and at her
passing there was no better team
anywhere or at any time Diamond's death
was totally unexpected probably her big
and Precious Heart just plain gave out
rest in peace our magnificent Diamond
you will greatly you will be greatly
missed
um Trump speculating about the cause of
death as well and as a reminder here was
their view about covet vaccines yes we
don't need to look at the community
right but what we don't need to happen
is what happened with Africa when Bill
Gates in them took that vaccine to
Africa trying to vaccinate they felt
like stuff can start right there in
certain parts of of Africa that's what
we don't need to you're not gonna make
black people not the guinea pig
no uh yo yo project right not black yes
today Billy yes the surgeon the Surgeon
General was talking to as a matter of
fact he was trending today listen I I
tell us what we need to know yeah but I
always look at the underbelly of what's
going on without the intuition in me
yeah that's my intuitive yes counterpart
yes what are you about to do here right
because what you're not gonna do you're
not gonna start vaccinating blackfo
right and we have to have a vaccination
card just to go to work so you're not
gonna do that and what it does is it'll
start with us first right right anyway I
think you get the point so listen
unclear if she died of covet uh the
today's voicemail is related to the
death of diamond I take no pleasure in
anyone's death vaccinated or
unvaccinated I never have a Donald Trump
Jr and others claim people on the left
want right Wingers to die of covid or to
die unvaccinated or vaccinated or
whatever that's absolutely insane there
is absolutely no evidence whatsoever
that I take pleasure or hope for the
death of any of these folks whether it
be Herman Cain or whoever else if indeed
it was a death from kovid and she was
unvaccinated that is a tragedy it's a
tragedy of weaponized disinformation
although uh we we know that against the
new variants the vaccine does not
prevent transmission or infection it
does reduce the odds that you die and it
has likely saved tens of millions of
people globally
um and whatever the circumstances are of
this death although I found her
political views disgusting and
deplorable
um and um contradictory to everything I
stand for
uh I do not wish harm on anybody and we
will I believe at some point find out
the truth about the death of diamond
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
produce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below